i just realized that the when i just did
problem number 14 i got a weird answer
because once again i cannot add and
multiply but just going redoing it just
so you get the right answer so you have
number 14
it says well they give you
a three a
dot dot dot and they say that each term
is three times the the previous term so
the next term is going to be 9 a and so
forth right
and they want to say they say the first
five terms the sum of the first five
terms is 605
and so what is a
well what are the first five terms
it's a
3a
9a
27a i'm just multiplying by 3 every time
81a
and this is always the part that i will
mess up you know this is 1a so 1 plus 3
is 4 4 plus 9 is
13 13 plus 7
13 plus 7 is 20 plus 1 is 21
and then 4 plus 8 121 a
is equal to and they say it equals 605
the first the sum of the first five
terms 605
a is equal to 605 over 1
and that is 5. much easier when you can
add properly
that's all i had for this video because
i just have to correct my mistake
see you in the next problem